50 years ago today the godfather uh
perhaps and certainly in my estimation
the greatest movie of all time started
unspooling in a theater near you and
joining us here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line to discuss
all of this is the man who earned an
oscar nomination for playing sonny
corleone in that film the great james
khan here on the rich eisen show how are
you james
i'm great as you said just great
i love it happy anniversary
happy 50th oh yeah on the godfather that
was my son who did that picture yeah
well i got to tell you man um it it is
just uh one of my favorites and i i let
me just jump right into it um how did
you get involved in the godfather how
did that come across
i did a picture called the rain people
which was a very kind of arthouse film
that coppola did when he was i was 28 so
he's a little older than me a year or so
and
i played a football player um
out of um
hofstra
where i actually went for howdy myers
was the coach
and and um
i so we worked together we were on the
road for like two or three months doing
that
and um got along very well
and
i don't know we just stayed friends and
when he got this
he came to me right away and then
of course then paramount got involved
i mean yeah and then he uh
he had this cast in his head
and we went up to san francisco
with bobby duvall with this kid named al
pacino
and brando
and uh they did some you know for a
corned beef sandwich you know we
we just ran around played around some
improvised scenes or whatever just
kidding around up there at san francisco
and um
anyway uh that was that then he went in
the picture got green lit he went to new
york
just got locations etc and then he
called me one night and said
jimmy i said what he says um
they want you to come in and test
i said test what you got a porsche you
want me to drive around the block what
are you talking about
so he says uh
no
they want you to play michael
i said what
you know it just
and i know francis so well you know what
i mean it's just
and and the success of that movie this
is a little added thing yes
that goes to your question you get
charged a little extra because of this
information okay sir
that
that
the success of this of the godfather
partially i mean
is the fact that francis and this is
what i told paramount before francis was
involved
that
he he's a mediterranean italian he's not
a brooklyn italian
in other words his his dad was lead
flowers for tuscanini
you know and i mean he grew up with
music and his his boys at the time they
they knew the cutting room when they
were three four years older
you know
in a film room and
so everything was music and art and this
and that there was none of these these
dems and those
and i think
because it became
such a family-oriented
film you know i mean it was
the people were you were concerned with
more than you were
the horses we say
so you were originally james you were
originally slated to play sonny from the
beginning and then they call up when he
called me francis want me to play sonny
right and so then now the the the oh i
came in to new york right he said come
on in and there must have been four five
hundred guys lined and lining
the walls of this big studio
ninth to seventh i couldn't remember
with every stupid accent you ever heard
in your life i mean
what are they doing here australian
accents i mean just
every actor you could think of was there
every everybody
and as a matter of fact i i he they
touched me for michael and then
they tested me
mario puzo wrote this book called
um the making of the godfather
and then he said if khan had boobs he'd
have played k
well you are you have reigns james khan
there's no question about that so then
how did you wind up finally getting
sunny because pacino read from michael
yeah because francis
why they wanted me but they wanted me to
play the other hole but which was
completely wrong and
you know francis
has his ideas and that's why he's
francis you know and
and al was he was something you had to
squeeze out you know in other words
the character of michael you had to get
him to that point where he was a
a leader and a boss and a crime
guy you know mm-hmm and uh
and that's what all did they and they
actually got in the fights you know
sometime because
al had it all pretty well mapped out in
his head
and francis maybe wanted them to move
faster i don't know but they'd argue a
little bit
and
by the way they didn't want brando
either oh great
we'll get into that a little bit james
come what do you mean they didn't want
brando
yeah yeah i mean but i don't know
because they all
i don't know they they must have with
comic books or something i don't know
i mean it couldn't we i heard brando i
wanted to do the picture if it would if
he would have done like a a postcard not
sure i mean
you know he was the guy he was great
james khan here on the rich eisen show
okay so then uh what was who was your
inspiration for sonny james how did you
decide to play him well
believe this or not you might believe
anything rich you're so gullible thank
you james appreciate that
and
i
the first scene we did was in a jengle
olive oil company you know when salazzo
comes up there
and
you know we don't mess with dope you
know this and that right
and then
brainerd goes down and they shoot him
outside the thing well in that scene i
was kind of lost it was the first day of
shooting
lost in the sense that
i i don't
study at night
i'm gonna do the next day that's not fun
i mean i like to
let everything come out of character and
not to be an artist but
but again yes to be an artist so the
i
i this feeling of what i thought sunny
should be like i didn't know
exactly i didn't have the the physical
stuff
or the the
the speech man or whatever it was that i
find
and i went home that night first night
and i was shaving because we were going
out to dinner or something
and while i'm looking in the mirror
i was a lucky guy because as a kid
i mean a young guy i was friendly with a
lot of these comedians i was a kid that
went along with like rickles and
dawn adams and all those guys
and rickles i mean
he just
drove me nuts you know
and he was so funny and i looked in the
mirror and i started being wrinkles you
know like you know
that's a nice suit when you have a clean
and burnt you know whatever
you know just
i so i i came in the next day
and i was wrinkled i made in front of
howardy's suit
that's going to run on you you pig you
know whatever i did
i just did like don rickles and believe
it or not
i hope you believe it and i hope you
haven't hung up have you i'm i'm hanging
on your every word james i like you
there buddy stay where you are okay i'll
hear you i just
i just um
started being reckless
you've seen had all day and and
and francis god bless him he let me go
you know he tells everybody like
now you know he called me just this was
a couple years ago he was in a
he lost a lot of weight and
she let
me improvise a lot so you're saying now
are you saying your inspiration for
sonny corleone and the way that you
played him no of the i i mean all uh
was rick in other words he's telling
people now like
was never written
bitty bop and all of that stuff was
never written i that
but it was because francis gave me the
comment to just go do
and someone said what does jimmy say
what does spider-man mean i don't know
he said would they say that in his
neighborhood let it be you know yeah you
got to put one in here
it's not you can't just walk up you got
to put one in his head but boom like
that's sort of what i mean
and then all of that so
and then he yelled at me for for for
saying you know you could have been the
multi-jillionaire if you
you know if you had that
thing uh what do you call
uh stamped or whatever oh yeah you got a
t-shirt or a bumper sticker or something
like that right
i said why did you tell me 50 years ago
you know you're such a smart guy
anyway i did all that even with
stuff uh sunny side where i grew up
where
you know it was like a guy would break
something of yours
take it out of here and break it and
and he threw money on the floor like
when i got the camera guy
that was also
uh improvised when i came out of the
wedding
walking by the fbi guys in the car
and i come down i'm walking back into
the wedding there's a guy there taking
pictures a bunch of guys there right
yeah you you know where just before i go
back in and i grab the camera and i
throw it on the ground i smash it
which made the property guy really happy
because it was obviously expensive
camera
and
and i looked down on it and i
just instinctively took out
like forty dollars on my pocket and
threw it on the ground
i walked in because as long as you paid
for it everything was okay
james cahn here on the rich
you know what i mean he let it go yeah
james cahn here on the rich eisen show
on the 50th anniversary of the godfather
is it true that brando needed cue cards
sometimes
for his lines
when he had long speeches no brando was
he was just great i love the man he's a
good guy you know
being around him was
really special because any any one of
those guys that said he wasn't
you know to their liking or something
they were lying they're full of crap
they spent their lives trying to be like
especially a lot of those english actors
you know he was just fantastic
and
very sensitive
that's just a good guy just a regular
guy
when did you know
james khan that this was going to be a
generational hit something that
that is in the lure of of movie making
the godfather when did that hatch when
did that maybe you're all pretty selfish
rich i mean i remember the first night
when they showed it
and then we went to sherry
and
i got so pissed off at francis why
because there was a scene that was like
i don't know i mean it was like eight
pages long between bobby and i before i
go
to al with the butter being and all that
you know he says we'll find out who's
gonna hit salazo
i mean the cop
yeah and
and it was like a long scene it was
and francis cut cut it out and just left
me the last few lines before
and of course we're pretty selfish to be
honest
even if i'm not honest i'll be pretty
selfish
[Music]
and uh
i thought i could think about and
everybody said you were great i was
saying like kiss my butt you know i
i don't know
and uh of course i i got over that but
that's how selfish we are you know which
is
i just forgot wow
so
then i don't know it's just it opened a
certain amount of theaters
they try to do everything wrong and then
they pull them back
and put put it back in to another 1200
and um
that's it it's just
it it just you know won the best picture
of all time again with the afi and
and the cast was great and we had a good
time see that's what makes success
do you having a good time especially
like your shows
were fun for the people who watch them
because you guys seemed like you were
having a good night
we do
and and and uh
and the same goes through i believe that
people in the audience
are enjoying themselves because they
can't put their finger on it
but if
they can tell that people are liking
what they're doing up there i mean it's
just some
artistic [ __ ] excuse me i'm cursing
you all for it i love it i i it's it's
you know i i i i just remember when i
did see godfather part two you know the
the end of it right
where you're back around the dinner
table
and
the scene the scene is you know where
michael's about to inform
you know your father that he's gonna go
enlist in the army
and
um you know and you're like break your
father's heart on his birthday and it's
just it's just what a way for that movie
to end
um
i just remembered you being back and i
just
i was excited because you know i all saw
the tollbooth scene and it was just
great to see it back on that screen
you know so last one for you uh
what
what do you think of when you see that
tollbooth scene again
i try not to it was pretty scary
i mean i'd be honest with you if
if there were no girls on this set i
wouldn't have done it
what do you mean
no because there were girls here how to
do it what am i gonna you know i got an
image here
[Laughter]
anyway um
yeah i did it
he put 147 scripts on me
in my jacket now these scripts are
they're brash
with gunpowder in the middle of this
little v that they cut into this one
inch
long piece of brass and put a
a sack of blood over the top of that v
and they sew it into your clothes
and
they have to make sure they're pointing
out because it blows the material out it
blows everything out
and they actually use those very same
squibs
on the car they they put them in the car
and put bondo over it and paint it so
it's strong enough to blow that bondo
out of the car
you know when they fire it
and they fire by putting a nail on this
nail board by putting a nail that's
attached to another electrical
thing and each time it makes contact
with another male and it each nail
represented one of the plugs so we had
over like
5 000.
all told
a couple thousand i forgot what it was
in the car and
in the car and in the in the booth
and
uh so i
like i say i wouldn't it it was pretty
hairy so it had to be like a dance you
know music you got to get your hands
moving right certain way because it
would blow a hole in your hand
and like i said
the girls would make me do that
james khan you are uh the best for doing
this i really appreciate it um you know
you're one of my favorites this movie is
truly my favorite
um
certainly in the genre and um can you
get me a job hanging out with you guys
anytime anytime you want to not your
picks and everything oh yeah you could
we we could figure it out for the
football i want to do is get baker
who's going to take this poor guy i
don't know i i'll tell you what james it
strikes me is he might have to either go
to seattle or wait it out after the
draft to see who'll take it i think it's
always left but i think there was like
there were two guys out of the whole
league that
might have made a play for him when he
was threatening to leave right and then
you look he's had 57 interceptions in
four years and i was like
oh well i know i have no idea but we'll
i'll i'll stay in touch we'll have you
back on whenever you want and i uh
appreciate you spending time on such a
momentous occasion all right say hi all
the guys say hi to the boomer i haven't
seen him either and uh he'll do that
i love it
you take care of yourself james
right back at you thanks again that's
james khan right here on the rich eisen
show on the 50th anniversary of the
godfather
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here